ok here is again the yardbird even early
in the morning he's playing like I'm
doing ok and this is game number 29 in
our everlasting match here I 1-3 so I
won 11 games lost 14 with three drawers
ok I'm going for a very safe set up now
and see what happens
I was well I said a safe set up it is
Knight to g5 an idea here I come on
let's do this let's do that intending
intending Bishop f6 I can play Knight
ce4 maybe have that's a decent defense i
can go night see you for okay or that
one I but here i can play each form is
this any good each form i can get were
six
I don't mind that's just it just
experiment here f5 yes why not now
you're threatening to take on g5 twice
now one issue is that she's always so as
he always has this Bishop before move as
well which is kind of annoying him after
trades Bishop reform
hmm this is really really not so great I
don't know h4 really looks kind of silly
now but ok ok so much fun he has Bishop
you form simply and didn't didn't do
that yeah I know I know but still we
should be for now maybe
I have to have to definitely get out of
the out of the sea file we're done with
both pieces yet so King now this is me
what did i do here it looks really weird
ever it looks really really weird I what
I wanted to do originally was I wanted
to play the Queen away here and f2 is
always under check it's really really a
problem if I go f3 this night g3
I don't know it's just not a very good
position okay other other squares are
not better but you can at least the
Queen on the ages some making things a
little bit more difficult frame as well
if you go screen f6 or queen e 7 I have
yeah here i can now i have Queenie to DD
takes Bishop takes I can play because of
the hanging queen on d aid now maybe the
position is not that bad I mean not not
totally clear to me DTX Bishop takes me
I don't know I know buddy what you
should do Brooks is seven or something
on the Queen Queen is seven Queen f6
Queen f six runs in two bishops III
though then I have to take probably at
some point Bishop b3 M is is in the in
the mix we should be three
i should i should actually i should make
sure i can play whoopsie one just for
awesome trades yeah I know maybe he can
just grab g2 where it's kind of greedy
but probably not a bad move still a G
two bishops III will take okay that
looks shaky yeah I played it well as it
usually does
maybe I can give up the exchange for the
a pond and I Roxy to we have Brooksie to
will probably finish me off how to not
maybe I can check be fire time morning
have to do this all other moves look
completely silly I mean Quincy to I mean
look to look silly should before check I
don't know I have to have to play
if i get to consolidate this it's just
not really that bad you should to see
three really this isthis is okay nothing
they got this pond which is kind of a
shame yeah without that it would have
been would have been nice causes us a
little bit something of would have could
have should have but still check yeah
normally you don't want to trade rooks
in this kind of situation with I want to
move the cons check check
check check check check check hopefully
is this really he is not working should
be sinks check check no it's just it's
just 11 tembo-no okay what for fates on
time I really think isn't this distance
it's okay i mean my points are kind of
dangerous here why does winning now of
course but how how exactly am i winning
I didn't see it King f six wins why be
five or what's the point if he does that
he fired for Bishop 26 year yeah he
allowed tons of counter play here with
with with my pawns even hear it starts
to get if he for black check of course
it's just I mean we didn't have any time
but I really got back into the game here
with the pawns a little bit even if it's
objectively winning for black what what
about this is there they should should
be a win ready for black something
convincing what he did wasn't convincing
really this is far far better than I
deserved rookie one look here we should
be for look-see for ya I I really
blunder this pawn him I can I can do
something like this
example and I really have two pawns for
the exchange and they are potentially
dangerous so he probably could have
finished me off in some other way look
here now maybe I keeping stuff envelope
yet now that's winning from black yeah I
actually played a little bit crazy in
the opening and it costs lots of time
and didn't lead to it didn't lead to
anything good like here yeah I felt that
shouldn't be too bad but probably it is
young black it's just how better
coordinated and it's a yeah like
aspartame his pieces are more active and
I'm not really this is not a very
harmonious position Bishop before was
winning immediately here okay you and
Jack curtains and here I'm sort of
hanging on a little bit but it's it's
really bad him okay wow thanks for
watching